est ce que vous connaissez le théorème
de la tasse de café
ce théorème il dit qu'il est impossible
de mélanger parfaitement une tasse de
café
c'est à dire que peu importe la manière
dont vous mélangez la tasse il y aura
toujours un point qui sera revenu
exactement à sa position de départ qui
trouve ce théorème intéressant hockey
qui ne trouvent pas intéressant ok on va
dire soixante dix 30 pour intéressant
voici un but partout le coup ce théorème
bas il semble plus vous intéresser
globalement et puis ce qui semble plus
vous intéressez vous allez avoir plus
envie de le comprendre et de le
mémoriser et pourquoi parceque ils vous
intéresse plus maintenant voici un
deuxième théorème s'appelle le théorème
de la somme géométriques et qu'on voit
en classe de terminale en maths et ce
théorème il dit quoi il dit que si vous
prenez un nombreux airs vous peut être
un plus
r + r carré plus trop petit point air
puissant scène et ça c'est égal à 1 -
herth puissance n + 1 sur 1 - r et ça
quand air est différente 1 parce qu'on
n'a pas droit / 0 donc y trouve ce
théorème intéressant qui le trouvent pas
intéressant j'irai 30 70 pour les
théorèmes et donc vous faites plus tôt
c'est peut-être là maintenant vous allez
avoir beaucoup plus de mal à comprendre
le théorème et al mémoriser pourquoi par
ce qui vous intéresse beaucoup moins oui
et donc le professeur qui veut
transmettre des notions à ses élèves
doit donc commencer par les intéressés
parce que si les élèves ne sont pas
intéressés alors ils ne voudront pas
recevoir de notion du professeur et
y'aura pas transmission donc deux cas se
présentent
quand le professeur de transmettre une
notion soit la notion intéresse déjà les
élèves dans ce cas là y'a rien à faire
soit elles n'intéressent pas les élèves
a priori et dans ce cas là il doit
commencer par les intéressés et la
question qui se pose alors c'est comment
intéresser les élèves à ce qui nous
intéresse pas a priori
on va prendre un cas particulier pour
répondre à cette question dans cet
exposé on va considérer le théorème de
la somme géométriques dont a parlé lucas
est alors y en avait qui étaient déjà
intéressés par ce théorème mais la
plupart d'entre vous n'étaient pas
intéressés à priori par ce théorème et
on va se poser la question comment
intéresser les élèves à ce théorème donc
pour ça on va faire une analogie
c'est à dire que là pour l'instant là
nos régions l'appel l'analogie du tire
bouchon
donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est intéresser
les élèves à ce théorème ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va remplacer les
élèves par des martiens et remplacer le
théorème par un tire bouchon et qui
pensent que les martiens sont intéressés
par le tire bouchon a priori très peu de
personnes est en fait à priori ils ont
aucune raison d'être intéressé pourquoi
parce que mars c'est ça hier c'est un
caillou sans herbe sans raisin 120 et
donc la question qu'on se pose c'est
comment faire pour intéresser des
martiens au tire-bouchon bon la première
approche à laquelle on pourrait penser
consisterait à donner le tire-bouchon
aux martiens mais vous imaginez bien que
ça n'a pas bien fonctionné si on les
marseille sont pas intéressés au
tire-bouchon donc si on leur donne le
tire-bouchon ils vont recevoir les
objets vont dire ok bon il est joli
temps objet mais enfin moi je m'en fou
quoi ça sert à rien nous on sait que le
tire bouchon il sert pas à rien le tire
bouchon il permet d'ouvrir les
bouteilles de vin dont l approche à
laquelle on peut la nouvelle approche
avec l on pourrait penser consisterait à
donner le tire bouchon est à dire en
plus aux martiens qui permet d'ouvrir
une bouteille de vin c'est ça ça va
toujours pas pourquoi parce que mars
c'est ça donc c'est un caillou sans
herbe sans rezéen 120 donc si vous dites
à des martiens en plus que le
tire-bouchon permet d'ouvrir une
bouteille de vin il va dire ok ben c'est
super cool moi je m'en fous toujours se
sert toujours à rien du coup mais pour
la majorité des français ça paraît
bizarre ça comme comme comme phrase
donc l'idée qu'on pourrait avoir 6
de faire goûter les martiens de faire
goûter le vin aux martiens et avec un
peu de chance les martiens pour
apprécier le vin comme la majorité des
français
alors bien sûr on vous conseille pas de
boire du vin c'est juste la trique à
titre d'exemple et comme les martiens
vont êtres intelligents vont
probablement aimer le vin mais du coup
ils vont avoir de l'intérêt pour le fait
d'ouvrir une bouteille de vin parce que
si ça veut l'ouvrir
ils vont pouvoir boire le liquide qui
est dedans et qu'ils aiment beaucoup
mais le problème c'est qu'ils sont
toujours pas intéressé par un tire
bouchon
pourquoi enfin ils sont intéressés par
l'utilité mais pas par la bouche en lui
même c'est à dire qu'on aurait pu
remplacer le tire-bouchon par un objet
quelconque qui permettrait d'ouvrir une
bouteille de vin ça aurait été la même
chose pour eux et peut-être que vous
d'ailleurs n'avait pas vraiment
d'intérêt pour le tire bouchon comme
nous on en avait pas avant d'écrire
cette présentation
mais en vrai le tire-bouchon sylla cette
forme particulière etc c'est pour une
raison très particulière et donc l'
approche à laquelle on a abouti pour
intéresser les martiens au tire-bouchon
consiste à ne pas donner le tir à ne pas
commencer par donner le tire bouchon
mais plutôt à commencer par demander
d'ouvrir la bouteille kiki qu'ils aiment
d'accord donc on prend les tirs les
martiens on leur fait goûter et melgven
et l'air maintenant à leur demande
d'ouvrir la bouteille de vin sans leur
donner tire bouchon et le comme il aime
le vin ils vont avoir envie de voir sa
bouteille d'eau qui vont passer dans une
phase de résolution
ils vont essayer de chercher une
solution pour versailles bouteilles de
la fin de la phase de résolution elle
pourrait être la suivante dans un
premier temps ils vont essayer de
pousser le bouchon
ceci pousse le bouchon le bouchon va
tomber dans le vin le vin va prendre le
goût du bouchon ils pourront plus
refermer la bouteille mais qui l'on
comprend que c'est peut-être pas une
bonne idée
il le redira à la place de pousser on va
essayer de tirer le bouchon mais sauf
que la manière traditionnelle tirer
bouchon c'est le prendre par les bords
sauf qu'on peut pas sur un bouchon donc
une manière de faire ce serait deux
entrées quelque chose dans le bouchon
donc on pourrait penser à rentrer un pic
sauf que si on rentre un pic on pourra
pas ressortir le pire enfin qu'en
ressortir à petit le bouchon ne partira
pas avec le pic est donc là on est
bloqué donc soit ils ont une idée de
génie
soit on peut peut-être un petit peu les
aider mais en tout cas ils vont arriver
à inventer la vie ce qui permis de
s'insérer dans le bouchon
et ensuite de tirer la vis avec le fait
et le bouchon partir avec la vie et la
boue ils vont arriver au tire-bouchon et
ils auront beaucoup beaucoup plus
d'intérêt pour le tire bouchon de cette
manière là donc et comment comment a
fallu qu allah pour si on récapitule un
peu comme en effet lucas pour intéresser
les martiens au tire-bouchon
ce qui a commencé par faire c'est
surtout pas leur nom leur bouchon il a
commencé par leur poser une question
comment ouvrir une bouteille de vin et
il s'est assuré avant que cette question
intéressait les martiens en leur faisant
aimer le vin et une fois que cette
question intéresser les martiens c'est
cette question qui les a poussés à
découvert tout seul ou avec un peu
d'être de luca le tire bouchon et à s'y
intéresser
c'est ça qui a permis aux verts
s'intéressent aussi aux bouchons et en
fait on peut généraliser
reprenant le cas de la notion tout à
l'heure si notion m'intéresse pas a
priori les élèves pour une bonne
approche pourrait pour les intéressés
c'est ne pas leur donner la notion de
commencer par leur poser une question
alors soit elle intéresse déjà les
élèves dans ce cas là très bien soit
elle n'intéresse pas déjà les élèves et
dans ce cas là on commence par les
intriguer et une fois que cette question
ait rendu intrigante
les élèves vont d'eux mêmes est repoussé
par la question et découvrir et elle
s'intéressait à la notion en fait c'est
pas un hasard si cette question
intrigante agit comme un moteur pour les
élèves en fait les questions
ils agissent pour un moteur pour tous
les êtres humains
par exemple les chercheurs ne font des
découvertes que parce qu'ils sont
cherche des réponses aux questions
qu'ils se posent c'est ça qui les motive
donc qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de
cette énergie du tire bouchon
c'est cette approche pour intéresser à
une notion qui ai commencé par donner
une question intrigante qui implique la
notion dans sa résolution
cette approche on a appelé intérêt par
questionnements et on peut la résumer
tout simplement en notant notion n
question intrigante cuit et la formule
magique c'est cuit impliqué nous on est
des mathématiciens donc on est dans les
formules cuit impliqué nca résume
totalement la proche de l'intérêt par
questionnement l'idée clé derrière cette
approche que nous avons introduites
c'est de faire connaître l'absence de la
notion pour mieux faire apprécier la
présence
c'est l'idée qui est vraiment derrière
ça on pourrait se demander est ce que
cette approche qu'on est en train de
vous présenter les nouvelles alors elle
est nouvelle dans le sens où elle n'a
jamais été formalisée comment la
formalise de là dedans mais il ya des
personnes qui l'ont déjà utilisé
auparavant donc par exemple socrates
poser des questions as personnes à ses
interlocuteurs dans le but de les faire
résonner
on a certains professeurs aussi qu'ils
utilisent cette approche là mais en fait
personne à notre connaissance ne le fait
de manière consciente c'est toujours
plus ou moins de manière aléatoire et
les gens ne se rendent pas compte à quel
point on fait ce set chose qu'ils
utilisent de temps en temps et
surpuissante pour intéresser les gens et
du coup notre objectif c'est de faire
connaître l'intérêt par questionnement
dans le but de que son utilisation soit
systématique auprès des professeurs ou
même dans la vie de tous les jours et on
l'a mise en pratique d'ailleurs cette
méthode dans le cadre de notre
association savoir pour tous ont été de
nous ont été donnés plus de 40 exposé
devant des lycéens et ils étaient tous
ces exposés étaient utilisés la proche
de l'intérêt par questionnement donc on
peut avoir quelques exemples en biologie
dans quelle forêt ira-t-on cueillir des
champignons en 2100 donc ça rejoint le
problème climatologiques d'auteur
quels sont les richesses de l'art
pauvres en histoire de l'art ou encore
qu'est ce qu'un bon en mathématiques
on l'a fait pour quelques disciplines en
réalité 4 mais en fait ça marche pour
toutes les disciplines
parce que toutes les notions sont le
fruit de questionnements donc plutôt que
pour intéresser plutôt que donner
directement les notions on peut
commencer par donner les questionnements
en philosophie par exemple ça donnerait
plutôt que d'essayer d'intéresser les
élèves à des essais sur le bonheur on
pourrait très bien commencé par leur
poser la question qu'est ce que le
bonheur en physique donc là il ya
beaucoup d'ingénieurs sûrement dans la
salle en physique plutôt que de donner
directement le principe fondamental de
la dynamique aux élèves
on pourrait très bien commencé par poser
la question qu'est la trajectoire d'une
pomme qui tombe d'un arbre ça marche
même en géographie
plutôt que de dire que toutes les villes
de france sont sur des fleuves on
pourrait très bien poser la question
quel est le point commun entre les
grandes villes de france
en fait ça marche pas que pour les
disciplines scolaires ça qui est
incroyable c'est avec cette approche et
que ça marche pour tous c'est que si
vous voulez intéresser des enfants au
fait que la terre tourne autour du
soleil
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant de
commencer par l'or de poser la question
pourquoi y at il des saisons est sûre
que vous aussi en fait vous l'utilisez
déjà cette approche au quotidien voyons
si vous voulez intéresser un ami à un
livre que vous venez de lire vous avez
pas lui raconter l'histoire de a à z
vous avez commencé par lui expliquer la
situation initiale et puis vous allez
vous ayant fait le mener à se poser la
question que va-t-il se passer dans la
suite pour lui donner envie de lire le
livre est ce talk en fait aussi est
construit sous forme de résolution de
problèmes d'intérêts par questionnement
pardon on a on voulait vous intéresser à
l'intérêt par questionnements et on a
commencé par vous poser la question
comment intéresser les élèves
alors reprenons notre cas tout à l'heure
qui était le théorème de la somme
géométriques vous souvenez de la tête
que vous faisiez devant ce théorème
enfin en tout cas que la plupart entre
vous faisait devant stoehr m voyons ce
que l' approche pas de l'intérêt par
questionnement apporte avec à cette
notion donc en 1750 l'espérance de vie
était de 25 ans en 2010 l'espérance de
vie de 80 ans
il ya des personnes qui pensent que les
premiers êtres immortels sont déjà nés
donc une question légitime qu'on
pourrait se poser c'est si on arrête de
mourir comment va évoluer la population
est ce qu'elle va tendre vers l'infini
ou alors est-ce qu'elle va finir par
stagner et on va prendre un cap précis
va pas faire le cas général on va
prendre le cas ou juste les français
sont immortels pour commencer et donc la
question c'est au petit pense dans la
salle que si les français sont immortels
la population française va tendre vers
l'infini dont qui pensent l'inversé
gérer 50 50 on va dire 50 50 hockey -
population actuelle en france on voit la
notte pap aa pour actuelle lé 2 67
millions d'habitants mais ça c'est la
population actuelle les gens ils vont
faire des enfants et pour calculer le
nombre d'enfants qui vont faire on prend
juste la population et on le multiplie
par le nombre d'enfants -
un par personne nos mères et ça fait p2a
fois est ressassé va être le nombre
d'enfants maintenant en termes de
chiffres en france r ça vaut à peu près
et 0,98 donc un français fait ranger en
moyenne 0 98 enfants et donc ça veut
dire qu'ils là toute la population et 67
millions feront 65,7 millions d'enfants
mais nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
pas la population de chaque génération
c'est la population totale donc il va
nous falloir sommet ces populations donc
si on a donc ça va nous donner cette
expression là on peut mettre p2 un
facteur si on some les nombres au bout
de deux générations en or à 132,7
millions d'habitants en france si on est
tous immortels mais ça c'est pour les
deux premières générations les gens vont
continuer à faire des enfants donc la
dernière génération elle va faire des
enfants nous pour obtenir le nombre
d'enfants on multiplie la population la
dernière génération par r donc ça va
être p2r carré et avec des chiffres ça
correspond à prendre 65.7 a multiplié
par 0 98 et s'adonne 64,3 l'appareil
nous ce qu'on veut c'est la somme on
obtient un 1er quart et qui apparaît et
maintenant la population passe de 132
millions à 197 millions au bout de trois
générations
mais ça on pourrait continuer on pouvait
par exemple calculer la population des
dix premières générations est pareil
donc la dixième génération aurait 54,7
millions d'habitants de personnes et on
nous ce qu'on veut c'est sommet donc
vous pourrez sommet encore ça et au bout
de dix générations la population
française si on arrête de mourir serait
de 668 millions d'habitants ça c'est la
formule qu'on a obtenus donc ça c'est ce
qui nous permet de calculer la
population pour les dix premières
générations mais en vrai on sait le
faire pour un pour deux pour trois pour
5 pour distancer faire pour cent en fait
on sait le faire pour une génération
comment en remplaçant 10 dans la formule
parraine dont on consomme 1 + r jusqu'à
hier plus ancienne et mais nous ce n'est
pas ce qui nous intéresse nous intéresse
c'est la valeur limite c'est-à-dire vers
quoi va évoluer cette somme quand le
nombre de générations tendra vers
l'infini et là en fait si je vous laisse
à cet endroit là elle explose et vous
serez incapable de trouver et ce qui va
ce qui débloque tout en mathématiques là
si vous voulez résoudre ce problème ce
qui débloque tout c'est le fait que
cette expression là
elle est égale à cette nouvelle
expression qui peut paraître un peu plus
compliqué mais qui en vrai est beaucoup
plus simple dans les deux cas et
pourquoi grâce au théorème de la somme
géométriques qu'on vous a présenté au
début
et pourquoi une fois qu'on a cette
expression c'est très facile parce que
si on remplace les durs à part 67 et r
par 0 98 dans notre cas ce terme là il
tend vers zéro
en fait quand vous prenez 0,98 si vous
le x 0 98 ça va donner un nombre encore
plus petits
ciboure aux multiples 0,90 à donner
encore un engloutis et si vous le faites
une infinité fois en fait vous allez
arriver à zéro donc ce nombre là enfin
si cette expression là elle tend vers 67
enfin faire cette expression à lille ça
c'est juste un calcul de maths tout
simple vous pouvez faire votre
calculette et à la fin vous vous trouvez
que la population finale de la france si
on est tous immortel sera de 3,4
milliards d'habitants et non pas infinie
donc ceux qui avaient parié sur
stagnation va gagner donc si je résume
un peu si si je vous suis si on résume
un peu pour intéresser les élèves
auteurs des menaces hommes géométriques
on leur a pas de l'asnl à la somme
j'avais dit que maintenant vous êtes
habitués on leur a posé plus qu'à vous a
posé une question si on est immortel
comment va évoluer la population en
s'assurant que la question était
intrigante en vous parlant des premiers
autre immortel né et c'est cette
question qui vous a mené peu à peu à
découvrir et à saintes à vous intéresser
naturellement avec l'aide de luca au
théorème de la somme géométriques si
vous n'avez pas tout à fait compris la
résolution dans le détail c'est pas
grave ce qui ce qu'il faut comprendre la
dent dans cet exemple c'est à quel point
l'intérêt par questionnement vous a aidé
à vous intéresser au théorème de
géométrie qu'est ce que ça vous a
apporté en termes d'intérêts c'est ça
qui est important
bon alors les avantages delà de la
méthode de cette approche
le premier j'espère que vous en êtes
convaincus maintenant c'est que ça
permet d'intéresser les élèves
énormément mais c'est pas le sait pas le
seul en fait il ya la compréhension ça
aide énormément à la compréhension parce
que ça fait connaître l'absence pour
mieux apprécier la présence
ça c'est une idée qui avait été un grand
mathématicien qui s'appelle alain caunes
qui avait dit c'est lorsque l'on sèche
sur un problème que l'on est vraiment en
train de comprendre ça aide beaucoup à
la mémorisation aussi pourquoi parce
qu'on donne une question qui est
intrigante pour les gens et cette
question implique la notion donc en se
souvenant de la question on se souvient
de la résolution et donc de la notion
cette approche rend les choses beaucoup
plus logique l'apprentissage ressemble à
une sorte d' enquêtes et en plus de ça
ça stoppe les a priori cirque un élève
qui est nul en maths
si vous commencez par les poser une
question il sait pas qui est qui fait
des maths et quand il s'en rend compte
c'est trop tard il est déjà intéressée
il a dépassé ses a priori frontignan on
aura une dernière question qui aiment
les spaghettis dans la salle ok bon sens
pour s'en venir de 6 9% est ce que qui
aime les ce genre de spaghettis la lépi
spaghetti crurent je parle au quai
quasiment personne en fait quoi quand je
vous demande si vous aimez les
spaghettis vous aimez plutôt ça ou même
mieux vous aimez plutôt les spaghettis
pesto ou les spaghettis carbonara où les
spaghettis bolognaises zulte ccspb tina
auquel vous pensez et en fait nous la
preuve qu'on propose ici c'est au ces un
peu la manière une nouvelle manière de
cuisiner les notions donc c'est en
groupe l'intérêt par questionnement
c'est aux notions ce que la sauce
bolognaise est au spaghetti et pour
conclure mon clan vous voulez ces deux
messages pour cette présentation
le premier message c'est que enseigner
commence par intéressé est le deuxième
message c'est que si vous voulez
intéresser quelqu'un obtient bouche on
ne lui donnait pas le tire bouchon
donnez lui demandez lui d'abord d'ouvrir
la bouteille
[Applaudissements]